I am taken to the picket lines because
my patients deserve better I've been
waiting for this surgery for two years
and now it's been canceled again these
are some of the people caught up in the
biggest NHS walkout in history
the wages just aren't compatible with
the cost of living
carmel's been a nurse for six years and
worked in the NHS for almost two decades
she'll join tens of thousands walking
out in protest overpay
every single day every single person who
is a patient is compromised by the fact
that there is not enough of us we cannot
deliver the care that we want to give
and that patients deserve and that's why
we are taken to pick at lands every
single day this happens people aren't
dying because nurses are striking nurses
are striking because people are dying
picking up my grandchildren I'm
frightened it's going to dislocate if I
pick one up while Kim joins countless
other patients whose surgery's been
canceled again due to Monday's ambulance
worker and nurse strikes
I understand nurses I've worked in Wards
I understand where they're coming from
but it's everybody that's been affected
by their strike not just nurses it's
patients families there are people worse
off than me that are being counseled as
well and it's not fair
meanwhile a direct appeal to the Prime
Minister from the head of the nurses
Union Pat Cullen a letter offering to
call off strikes for a new meaningful
payoffer the director of England for the
union doesn't accept the argument higher
wages fuel inflation much of that money
goes back into the economy and doesn't
fuel inflation what it does is goes into
taxes National Insurance it goes into
the local economy with people spending
power increasing but crucially for us
the the really important thing is that
there aren't enough nurses to deliver
the care that's needed
the health secretaries called the
walkouts regrettable but says they
accepted recommendations of the
independent pay review body no reaction
from number 10 though
the prime minister is being described as
increasingly isolated by unions as nurse
strikes were called off in Wales due to
a new payoffer and negotiations have
continued in Scotland as well but for
ambulance workers physiotherapists and
nurses here in England with no movement
from the government it appears there's
little hope of the biggest strikes to
hit the NHS in 75 years being called off
nobody wanted to reach this point but
now at apparent stalemate the NHS and
country is braced Adele Robinson Sky
News